9 i sat with philipp klöckner in the
podcast study in front of cameras but
unfortunately one camera failed there is
no video of the conversation we had
about his worst
and his best shares of 2021
his forecast and my forecast for
22 and how he  managed to pull out
a thousand times this race from a business as investment
all that comes
now has not in the video but here
in the audio a
warm welcome next to warren buffett's bottom by the way
sometimes a happy new year is sitting
here next to a hand-made warren
buffett doll that my two colleagues
by roxy it's going to be hard i think you
'd appreciate it somehow somehow did
n't even make it to be a guest exactly
that's fun too we have the
oracle of ostvorpommern and the oracle
of ostvorpommern next to grandma's
so excited the oracle will
have but  First of
all, for a long time I wasn't so aware myself that
you ever have it  now also on the
supervisory board one notices our
generation is growing again the digital
for seo people like you i also
now in your case with home to go so
that we are now also unusual
for you as a pack went public
because  you are back
largely critical but how come you
know best that i
trust more somalis last but in that case
i knew the market very well yes a
lot of so-called navigation
models workers as well as classics meter
search vertical search marketplaces that
is a  a little bit meinhof that's why it was
a good fit i know the industry
very well used to be at if you
've worked a lot at ideal
travel business can be responsible for the
industry
i know the team very well have been
working with them for a very long time
and actually
have at the very beginning  stressed already worked
for a bit the learnings and
want us wrong gema  cht got in
there and actually found
a great way there that he
didn't manage to build up a big club housing player again in a capital-efficient manner
. They did that
great
and when they went public
or managed the market through the spec, so to speak
were
encouraged to build the most useful supervisory
board possible and so the management board
then approached the
general meeting because they were elected to of
course fulfill the normal
duties of a supervisory board but of course
also to bring in expertise and be available as an
advisor, which is
surprising that the company ended up  to the
brokers
that was at the time i think one of the
different options that were
available there was obviously good
chemistry between the
ones that klaus hommels did the pool test a long time ago that worked
because the model is
not very easy to explain  so
I would assume is  so that the
specs sponsors understood that better
and had the confidence
that it makes sense to bring it to the stock exchange
you are absolutely right because of
it, becks is generally quite
critical that doesn't mean that everything
becks somehow there is also an example
that is developing well  but
overall the asset class has
clearly underperformed the market in
the past which is why there are of
course consequences again about
respect coming to the stock exchange because they
might not belong there,
for example, that this state of palestine, for example, has
many 70 80 percent - have  we
review the last
podcast
that speaks for the fact that not
only quality is coming to the exchange but
i know that i'm not the
target group for the specs always come 14
and 10 euros to the exchange should now be
at 55 so have now for now
not performed that well yet that could be due to
the liquidity of the share so that's
just not possible  there is a lot of volume and that is
very difficult i think
people are still avoiding the
travel market simply because of the
uncertainty that results from the curves
i think it will have to take
some time to explain the model to all investors and analysts
you can definitely always see it
somehow  somehow as a big player
at the same time that always creates
space for the senate anti-concept or
somehow the fair model the model
for the small house it's by
no means the entire so in the airbnb it
probably hasn't even removed 10 20 percent of the
apartment inventory on the
platform  so there is a
sufficient market there
and she says
laubig peaceful is a problem because many large funds simply change hands a stock that does not yet have enough
transactions every day, so to speak, probably
not enough shares every day
, sometimes we are not allowed to invest at all
, but in the long term, well, i
can  Of course I can only
express this to a very limited extent  believe in
the campaign i'm really looking forward to
working together and in the future i
'll at least buy shares rather than
sell them that i
'm not at all worried about which ones that's
actually a very long-term perspective and
also 100 percent in the campaign the
team believes a lot
it's about time for you it's not that long ago
but it's not just about
the four meetings that you have then,
you have to
prepare very well for them and
also meetings and updates in
between with the management team,
maybe  even with the one with the second
level to understand the company better and
also to help a bit
i would assume that's not
reasonably remunerated in general but
i would assume
some it is about the company going
public in general that's exactly
what it is  not yet six a day ne
unbelievable and it is also not I
think in the dax it would be sixth of course
lig with the area
not yet quite like that and medium to high
five places I appear but choose
what over the sea who wants to can hardly assume in the
second look
that you will
actually work on it for several weeks a year
and that’s really okay that’s
natural  still a very good
salary but there is also a lot of
responsibility
a bit of risk what you should also remember
how big it is in this
case the former emea boss of
airbnb and wafer is a manager of easy
corp so barry diller
rometsch and  children something that belongs to them
who used to be at booking was also
very good in the segment you have a partner
from inside
then a partner from dexter
also christoph schug i must have
forgotten someone and do you have
someone from the affairs the audit
tax advice scenes too  the audit
committee gaal is very appropriate and i
think it is very well selected to be honest
i would  me if you put the
capital together so so so so much
specialist
expertise from the
documentation marc christ you
probably not that
easy so i think it worked out quite well
and the
job so far has been super exciting so in the
end it’s the same as with  All companies are
happy if it's from
Germany then shares a unicorns after
currently 1 but it is
quite possible in perspective to install players from it
or even more
so in that respect okay so what's that
otherwise you'll break the stock market
from all other perspectives  so
what surprised you the most positively this year
what do you want the best
stocks from the of course that
haven't changed all that much the last mistake
i've been claiming this all year long
i think it was
the biggest surprise last year
so just now  From a German point of view it was
definitely a bit of the decline of
teamviewer, the three four  tel
have lost value that I think it was the
last time we talked
we both started quite harmlessly very well
I'm so brutally high margin
had somehow 56 percent ebit margin
or something like that a real cash cow where
now but more and more  has shown
that although they are still relatively
profitable, they say they are only
growing in single digits compared to the
free one, so and profitability
is also suffering a bit because the
operation leverage means, say, that
if you grow very quickly, then the
ebit increases disproportionately
works the other way around, of course,
exactly so that you don’t grow anymore,
then the costs continue to increase for a
while, then the margin shrinks a
little bit
, you can see how important growth is or
how high one is valued on the stock market at the moment
, how fast you grow and
that if you don't meet the practice time
anymore and want it punished hard
for me too m  it that actually the worst
of the last year I
had
[music]
here in the podcast after
that I talked about it privately and thought to
myself
that's a cool company because it's
also profitable and because all the worries
you have that will ever be profitable that's
how everything was  there was no question
then we were very courageous with this whole
sports federation by the way you say okay you could have done it differently basically first of all whether you could
do
such
deals and so i was very optimistic
and
would have thought okay maybe you can
always with  such dynamic
stocks lose or lose 20 percent in value
but i have lost 70 percent since then
was reality you can see very well
but that you actually
when you deal with stocks
when you pick individual titles that you
really have to research very deeply i.e.
saw on paper  that's how it looks
like I also bought it for a short
time relatively early on
sold for liquidity reasons
but also with a small loss
and so you would have the only problem
is that former employees of
motives who founded the test
apparently have a very good go to
market significantly manage to
advertise customers or to throw from the defect
with cheap ones  go at it and that's
exactly
how it can happen very quickly,
and when growth has flattened out,
then you get this, this
growth premium, so the big picture,
that would simply no longer be
used, it then comes to such a compression
of the master team and then we are
investors just
maybe that's easier for a company
to buy and no longer counts 15
times that quickly it can then
adjust the expectation of course everything
about yes if you come back to
growth it can now
turn around again quickly but
so quickly  you can then lose grace
and I thought that it was also a
An example is for stocks that actually
suffer from the fact that they could almost be even
better in the valuation
because from an American point of view they are
not seen by oliver stone
because they look at their
home market companies and teamviewer is
their own company that could be valley's
model  yes and so i thought to myself ok
at some point i will understand
that there is something cool in the
german province
but it didn't come to that and it
really at the time on
paper was really underrated
[music]
but well you can too  say
congratulations to permira
i think the stock market is right they sold off private investors at the
perfect time
and after that
it gets very thin very quickly or
the best paid in absolute
terms makes many dax seo's look like around
70 million salary but it's just now
were that stock options
may have lost value again
can't immediately except
usually but
that's exactly the question what's
left is probably so much
but still a lot for sarah dax
salaries and even more for even more
money
otherwise if you listen to her like I said
you have twice that  week of
intensive stock discussions with
doppelgangers up to, for example, even now
I don't think I was a fan
of Tui Lufthansa stocks last year. That's exactly
where we saw it very critically
that it was saved with taxpayers' money,
so ultimately every
German citizen is five in it and
I think roughly then  we
counted
the house that was at the beginning of the year
they were 7 half euros now at
275 or somewhere around three euros
when the state money is not
managed so well i also wonder what it
is worth saving now so they are
not somehow  systemically relevant or
whether we have any cruise
ships so if in doubt you can in my opinion
go bankrupt g  let the marriage go and then
a few ship funds or
investors are stuck with their papers and
the foundation is sold again and
operated again i don't understand where
the german interest is to save it to
be honest the
issue was my children's jobs
are not at all  I think as many
as came out on a cruise ship
let's see how many
German jobs there are clearly
workers' party almost 20,000 employees in
total
on the other hand it's fair to say that
the state of course also invested a few very
good ones so the cure was gone,
so to speak it didn't have any effective ones  vaccine
or no sufficiently effective
vaccine but the
investment was second tripled for
the german state even after the
loss afterwards
lufthansa also in germany
good investment probably from the point of
view of the taxpayer of dice
all in all went quite well at
lufthansa now  better understand
why it still seems worthy
to be saved at tui we
were relatively critical at the time because I
remember that I somehow
looked over it a little longer at without a share with difficulty about
tui and then
thought that surprised me that they were
worth so little  are as a market cap it was
already in the low billions because
there are large assets zynga planes and
ships and so everything is okay that
's a case maybe where
the assets are worth more than
the company is open right now
but okay let's see how it is
so there is also a no no positive
story from his point of view in the last
year this the rescue operations especially
at tui not
something that touches you on the negative side
so on the extremely positive side
there are negative
things that even the imminent
regulation in china or partially
then regulation in china set in
which affected the shares of most chinese
companies  hmen has almost halved what was
previously relatively fairly valued because of
exactly the risk your private
hit yes exactly I was invested in tencent
and alibaba and took
the full losses with me binder stayed
invested but
what you can already see
I would not be somehow
politically Chinese now  approve of politics,
what should i do, you always have to put it first,
but what you are doing in terms of
regulation seems to be at least
effective, so that at
alibaba not only do the courses react,
but the stitches have
actually melted at alibaba, i
think that’s easy  the effect that
someone who previously had a monopoly or
maybe a
duopoly with tt.com, which was almost regulated,
was made relatively easy to achieve because
their market power was relatively easy to enforce, so that if
you keep up with it, the
monopoly meshes will melt away and
the share will actually melt away as a result  doesn't
look quite as good as it is now
still very cheap but considering the
risk
I wouldn't say that it's a
bargain that you would definitely
have to collect, so I think you can see
very well that the markets are turning
to monopolies that are better regulated so that those
who make profits can also be gone very quickly
Speaking of China, one thing
I noticed last year and
I haven't found it anywhere
yet, maybe I'll make up
my mind that for the first time really
relevant Chinese brands are arriving in Europe
and two long years not like that
, he can say which ones have been extended
workbench products and stuff like that now
at the latest you with this seemed so
this new retail
megastar all of a sudden a chinese brand
has really arrived in the german end customer
area european we
have global end customer area you
can see that now also in the car area it’s
burning again place so
I didn't really
expect that and a  not for the german
economy either he hopes that it will
be because i always thought that the
brand you have there that you can defend that is
also a bit culturally bound
maybe cannot be
quickly taken over by chinese companies
but i found that interesting how
if something
like that happens we have to see
if it won't be the next one of
course then how many people are
ordering because twice at the moment they are
growing incredibly fast and probably the
only one is the brand so the question
is i can do that i think we are
both not the target orient i think
so i don't know how the cow is
listed the brand say how it is
perceived then but i think it's about the
younger audience definitely knows the product
and has probably
already ordered it the question is
how  you often do that how satisfied are
you with the quality in the long term
then everything is really crass like them
we've grown further around the world in a wide variety of markets and we've had cell phones
for a relatively long time with chanson and jay
and
i think with cars many players will also
come to europe from china
technologically probably not that
far behind
exactly the
question is me  I mean the danger
that any trade wars which
we can't really afford
girls will be part of it again for just as
long and so I'm
actually in a series of situations from there
I would also assume that we'll assume that we'll
see more and more in the
future are already trying
and that will always work out very
well i think what about your
johnston is yes if you know the ford
also big fan of cloud titles of
any kind also which is rather quiet yes
one they had
ran very well in between then had in
In the last Q4, almost all of
them dropped between 25 and up to 50
percent, just the good ones
ran so cloud flair exactly cloud player
you can say data talk is what
is still going very well
traust the whole cutie sector sentinel
mansiysk it further
i think that you will see there or
what will continue and 22 is there
that i that  a bit separates the wheat from the
chaff so that now
everything that is big and cloud and saas is no longer hyped up
, but that you look
a little more closely at it
, fauxpass tyrolean fortin also say
where is either fast growth
or is it profitable and growing moderately
there is definitely a title where
it just doesn't work that well anymore
somehow a c3 or german extra
should for example on the stock exchange came
last
year for example the sfx hardly and
has more turnover more loss than turnover
that's the way it is  Titles that just
don't have enough momentum anymore because they're supposed to be part of the cloud database, or
if there's a bit of a split  t and
people are looking at
it in a differentiated way but i think the good titles
will continue to run and that
beijing is becoming more important so
just buying a cloud index
is perhaps no longer the best
solution for
22 and what is also becoming more difficult
i think  I will have
four ecommerce tailwinds last year, at least
for some and I think now that the
posco rover will have to curve a little bit
and the
shops will be open again, you will
notice that for many it will be much more
difficult to grow somehow Alsace has
difficulties  quarterly book is not going well
and this is also being generalized very strongly
so juwi is
not really building up super numbers
you will be beaten up a bit with the
swedes also under priced exactly
although they relatively outperform now
no buy recommendation i think it is
one of the better ecommerce titles there
there and I find that almost a
bit unfair  s which, although they
actually outperform by landing on the lower level, and
the whole thing doesn’t do so well either, so
that they then become a bit
baggy, but that’s a kind
of clan-like thing, so
the establishment of the investors, the analysts’
clusters in  Shares of course also in
industrial markets in Germany and if
you are then in the wrong segment, i.e. the
ecommerce fashion is on it and you book
Acer’s bad quarter to deliver thanks
, your share will be punished
because the sector is simply set to
underperform and so it is the same
with the two emerging ones  Market titles
that are now doing very well, such as
Schoppe in Southeast Asia or Mikado Libre
in South America, they are also valued so highly and have performed so
well that since
growth will now slow down a bit
, there will probably
be a correction in the
Malta mushroom again  guess how commerce
is likely to underperform by 2022
at least on the stock market, of course,
I still believe ecommerce, but if you have seen
these dream growth figures over the last
two years, yes, I
think they will drop away a bit
and everyone is now looking for a bit of
the new base line, but how
fast they will grow like now in  future
of which level
go back step by step with some spices even i believe
that you even have declining sales quarter to quarter
or
new customers are paying or active users are
paying
but that makes it exciting because the more
exciting is then the right
one you pick a little bit  the good
ones in the jar the bad
ones in the jar that means you can tell
you're listening to her
probably very, very comprehensive
stock interest knowledge for the
digital and listed area
worldwide actually
what did you last buy yourself as an individual title
so and
to derive from that what could
possibly also be  now come in the 22nd year g  ut
running so it's not a recommendation yes to
show the facts what i
believe in
2022 so you can connect it with such big
trends that's one thing but
we are both watching the podcast how it's
growing we see how the advertising prices the
advertising demand is going as well as with it  the
alliance is growing although there is more and more
inventory gaining more and more new
podcast i think there is still a lot of
momentum on the demand side
there are the two first of all if you
want something solid certain
spotify will definitely
benefit from it and there are also smaller ones
fast growing marketers studios
guest from sweden is relatively large
growing at i think 90 percent
is not quite profitable yet growing
definitely fast enough
to be allowed to be profitable still in the uk
there is audio boom also almost
doubling to the advantage of the same
year last year  that looks very
promising so i
think a podcast thinks so  bt could or
spotify audio podcast exactly those are listed
on the cottbuser via the stock exchange so to speak
with pellets the
best animals are exactly the stock exchange
are listed you have to check whether
there are bows and trucks maybe not in
all trading apps because they just don't have
one  are really big stock exchanges are but are
they say so the titles
at least look like I said you
can never change it is really really quick
at the moment they are good
looking I think that applies to service so you
read an increasing number of threats to
the  classic as a kraut strike that
has been running for the last two decades
this year sentinel one and
seascale are going public they are
also very good from my grow
faster than kraut climb no
becoming profitable everyone is already
close to it both are working in the broadest sense
service is cooling down  for example the so
that developers can connect securely to the cloud
or all employees
in companies not secure  connections have
complained that external interventions are being
avoided we continue
and the third major trend is i believe
that the liver protects the lack
of workers huge problem if you read
more about the about a turn no matter where you
then there was in every pane we are looking for service
staff we are looking for  staff is
really overly accurate and we say we know
that there is a shortage of skilled workers, so of
course a digital scene is
omnipresent, but i think what is
special and what has not really
caught on as knowledge is that
actually affects all areas of the economy
, so it has come in handy, so to speak  too
late mainly because the train conductor is leading
because there is no staff does not
have to have to go to the restaurants yesterday
in the rocky mountains can't push a
bike so they have record holders I can't open anyway way lack of staff
and I was arrived on the train at the
station these are jonas  live or
say so immediately for 14 euros per hour  de
at the beginning on weekends there are over 20
euros or on public holidays is
the whole staff i always ask myself
that's amazing because if they
are, the people haven't
disappeared now it can work there
is a short-term effect and
a very long-term effects macro
effect  is that the
buga generation or the baby boomer generation is out instead of
not out but first retiring
so some deserved pensions
and in germany alone i think
about a million people retire every year
but only 500 come to the
job market  so it's completely clear
that there will be medium to long-term
gaps for which we
don't have a plan how we'll fill them,
so it's really just about
qualified immigration, maybe
even less qualified people say
now that there are quite simply jobs where
we need people and a few  people
have so there is this film great
reconstruction resignation je na  Depending on
how optimistic you are that a
lot of people will just
have to re-choose their personal preferences from working life, many
have become self-employed, many have
also given up work or,
so to speak, their parents have extended their time
or something and all of that does
n’t help now  the labor market but there
are players who could benefit from it,
the dormant
workforce, i.e. the people who are theoretically
able to work but don’t want to or
who would change jobs, i.e. the
active search, i.e. what that what lives on
in stepstone or monster now, that
always happens  less of what is
actually a challenge now to get people
out of their jobs through push marketing
or to reactivate them in the
job market and that means, for example,
in the usa they are growing very well
have also doubled in the last quarter are
profitable and i think the market has a
tailwind and  the good thing is
that we stop n  not rated as
a saas company so they now have
five times the turnover said bill which is
relatively low although they are
actually very similar in terms of the mayo
structure they have an extremely high
cross machines as is the case with the sas
typical very high recording rapping
good references from the  customers that end up
spending more every year because of their need
and i actually think it's
really nice if in 2022 this stars and
sketches fetish of
investors stops in the
scene but also in the public markets
because there aren't that many
really rational reasons  why a
company that
works the same way from the lowly ones should somehow be worth 34 15 times as much
just what it says on it so of
course you say the script so
there is a login and you change your
software product not as quickly as
the marketplace for work maybe
but  so to speak, our theoretical
in practice know exactly in practice
how often do you have the ma  rktplatz for no
idea the preferred ecommerce
marketplace or travel marketplace changed in
the end I think you have a high level of
brand loyalty I think the malus
you give the normal models the
federal government you give the saas models there are
both a bit exaggerated and
if that  would be trembling
model what
you could also relate to the podcast marketer
or so have or
audio book there is still a job market in russia
headhunter group
very good political risks through the
country we have monster and stepstone
steps and is not very
likely to arrive  dared to go to the stock market
and i can invest there but
monster is listed on the stock exchange works
better than ever there is
still recruit holding is a
japanese holding but they
very cleverly
bought glass there a few years ago so the two are
probably the second largest  job
market places in the world they are like that too
Possibilities and I would say that
tends to be all-wheel
drive compared to the rest and
undervalued
if this macro trend
continues, but I don't see what stands in the way of
that. To be honest, our time
away from the stock market
a whole series
of business and investments how much so
in the year of the annual profit
maybe a dozen so exaggerated
i would say that of course but
definitely more than before it
has 12 x 2 pieces and then a ticket each time
always around 50 yes
earlier  if you think about it, you make 20
25,000 today, around 100,000 euros, it seems
, your fingers through the through the
easy the cheap money and the
amount of the rounds is of course clear
you will probably experience it yourself
here with which he also invests in many
exciting
things  making 25,000 articles at some point
is not that easy, but it can
be accepted  That's exactly what you want
and then in the end you somehow
somehow
own 0.2 percent of the company or something like that,
then it must be very big
that at some point you'll get a significant amount of money
back out
there, but that's the way it was
somewhere between 25,000 and 100,000
the best thing, which is
probably over for the time being
because I got it right now
is also significantly more accepted, yes
, it was a relatively high ticket
because I somehow just had the
liquidity or it was very
opportunistic because there was more to
do  So far it seems that there has been a relatively
traffic jam but it was because I
haven't sold any of the children yet
, exactly so I
once made a big ticket for the
100 million round and I
was allowed to make a very small one on the
previous rating
has more than 200 8 the other is
already well over ten ex and I
thought that was exciting as if
ma  n assume that you now
invest a hundred times that would be
ten million that 400 times
that was much smaller tickets to say that
was well under 100,000 the
500,000 I have on the 100 million okay but
still it's already done
the storm is turning exactly but  so
don't worry that it's
going to get under the wheels now if the
consolidation is going to happen then somehow
you because of all the
liquidation preferences and
before bills this results in when the
brand is cleaned up that
at some point you'll be a much smaller part of
something  bigger has what that
maybe I'm tradable and then
let's assume I think it's right
that there will be a war on the market for
consolidation so on
New Year's Day we already got the first
message that you livre glover grabbed
the many sees Europe
on the way  your beer, schnapps and so
on, so they are
suddenly very  big i think that
will continue
i think it gorillas he is someone who is going to
consolidate so
may also be able to buy it is not an island
but now my personal
understanding or judgment
i think that we
have seen that soccer players
have allegedly withdrawn in germany  if you didn't burn so much money
for it then i think it
might make sense to
try it but then cancel it again early on
i can imagine that
others will either buy it or
withdraw again so
don't worry you still have your
investment  on the same rating
again how do i think you
have a bit
so the probability that's
doubled again and that too in
less than twelve months i think it
's relevant big and i would
say it's almost a bit safe from the bottom
because  I think there
might be a kind of flora  t at 2
billion or
so anyway the judges would in
fact maybe even strike once
then there
would be a signal now that it's going to
be hard to read and the next round
so i think before it
comes to one someone will download it
always beatable at a certain airfare was of
course the the us players have
to start with their growth first of all
money here in turkey
very early they are valued at seven and a half
billion i think i
think they have a hard time organically
in continental europe  to be honest
, the 100% would be rational would have
to withdraw from my power
but they need a story us trade as the
largest in turkey cannot last
long that means they have to win something in
europe that means i think they
will have to buy something or
withdraw  but i also believe
that a rough idea they want next
year i believe in the stock exchanges  e are valued at 15
billion if they
go public they would have a good
currency to buy more players, so to speak, and
i think they would of course
immediately be on the flinc so also cuba i
think all of them are having a hard time
gaining a foothold in continental europe and
in london, which is also a very hot market
,
that means they would probably
either be quick and founders would have to buy in
the end if you want, because
they have admitted that they
can't really do it that doesn't mean
that I'll stop
trying to do it organically tomorrow  but
maybe there are still a few
million marks to be squeezed simply to keep the
prices in the other east under
control and to put pressure on the market
, but
I would assume that one of
them would have to sell themselves, so to speak, to
enter the European market
and then become  nimble and chorus, of
course, the protested players and
so that would also lead to ratings  city
ich you think are higher than the c
rrent ones
ay it is of course I wish I don't
think anyone would expla
n any more than one it's a n
imble one that still falls below a billi
n I think it's rat
her unlikely [musi
] at the moment besid
s  many other
things you
really have to respect the colleagues from vodafone for how
many ideas they always come up with
to make their business customers happy the
latest is called dieweiß lifecycle
management that means for four
euros 95 per month and phone number you can
take care of it as a company as a company
that all of the smartphones in the
workforce are secured if
they ever break down you
get a new analyst the next working day at
a flat rate that is quickly
repaired a smart
device management that means configuration
distribution also the back from the current
devices vodafone for a  company for
the whole document sc  liability for the entire
smartphone fourth, so to speak, if
you want to know more, it’s best to google vodafone
and the wayss lifecycle management
other companies from the portfolio who
have followed the no so now
for villagers know a lot, yes the
exciting thing is i have in our
own podcast describe me
I always tell people I almost always stay away
from business angel investments because I
believe that the returns are good compared to the
public markets. At the
end of the year I actually took
the trouble to write everything in the table
that before, to be honest
never made i thought i heard that too
unfortunately were actually
i would look back at all the other
investments come the
funnily enough almost exactly at the same tvp iii
so say the making of the
money used again alcohol made it much
quicker you have to say
but say in  Overall, the
portfolio is almost as good, which
surprises me  cht has but there are also
totally out but just a few films
from it can know the world so what
works well so advertising
spoken by experienced people in Germany
there are jobs that do something very similar in the
German
market I'm involved as a consultant and shareholder,
so to speak  the function is extremely
good the old windows email about
it you can contact extremely smart founders and
a great team behind them that i also
met
who benefited just as
much from the lack of
great mesh
races from the shop will probably soon be the next
round and are  well on the way to
maybe becoming a unicorn
a year
ago i invested in fashion food
it's sort of a kind of
operating system for the creator
community so that could be
exciting for me and you as a podcast horst
may we be too  watching now and then
beats us to say a few things to me
back and forth you can still
said do more than we work yes that
doesn't mean
that i find it exciting
i've made a cooperative they're
not all public
yet so i don't know if i can talk about everything
but i have a bit of an e-commerce
software infrastructure
invested
i have done two things in
holland that will be out soon how do you get to
holland so they have
something like this happening over the network a lot more
happens somehow through the podcast
or simply over time or the
network that you
get more and more of, so to speak  that are still being
offered that you hadn’t seen
before that helps, of course, but
they might still fit your profile well
change can now
benefit greatly because many current providers are
bankrupt  go through the energy prices, which
have risen very sharply if you
have calculated fixed costs
then you are calculated as a market that
means you can now have a
flexible price where they add a fixed
fee which is very transparent
for the customer
and you are  no longer intensified to use
as much electricity as possible
to get it really cheap, but
you have an incentive to use as little
electricity as possible, but what you
pay for has a fixed
premium on the market
price, transparency, the digital model works well for expats in
Germany  also because it is in english
and german i found it very good
that you always change the topic
what about your old part
-time employer rocket i mean there it
was advised for many years
but we also have very operational on the
topics on that line of shops
back then it was talked about a lot more is
a company it needs a universe
to  jumped where it was your
turn i think
various other things
became international it was on and
you don't hear anything and then you're
definitely the windows of the right
share culture and there too the rocket did surprising things well well
i actually do  not so
much with rocket in the last few years,
simply because
there is relatively little in its operative business year, as
I understand it, rocket and
gft are still investing in new companies at a relatively high
rate
worldwide so also a
few in germany wasn't i
no longer with a focus on germany
i would say exactly they're trying yes
everyone tried to take rocket off the stock market
and so to speak called
paul singer or asset management onto
the scene who typically did something
one perhaps most likely event basin
westin angeles al  so the search explicitly
for such takeover situations or the
listings, so if companies
are to be taken off the stock exchange, then buy
lastminute.de to simply apply as much pain as possible
to the
people who have the actual plan
and then let it, so to speak  very
well prevent him from
interfering with the process if you said that as a mixture between
arbitrage and almost bowling or
blackmail was perhaps too far have said
simply creates
the scenario where he
[music]
is paid very high that he
withdraws again testifies or
gives up his shares again  but could now
also formulate it positively that he
does what he does and triggers a certain market
hygiene, namely that you can't just list
companies as below market value
somehow because
types like him prevent it
and work against it, there are also
market observers  I think I
have found it desirable at the point,
so you can a  On the one hand, what
does it mean for you? A short fishing
activity, so you can see that
something isn't quite clean. I throw
myself on it and try to
make the bearings or somehow threaten trouble
that whoever should pay for it, on the other
hand, take care of the hygiene in the market
just as i am i quickly always has
the function but that it
compensates for information
asymmetry starts now in the event
that i think 42 euros had come to the stock exchange
then between germans
well under 20 there should
also be private shareholders
are finally settled with the lists so
as this then the
owners wanted to take the company back from the stock market
and asset management will now ask 35 euros
they will probably get it and
due to the timing so that it happened after
november the old
shareholders must already
I agreed,
at least I didn't pay the same
price anymore, as I understand it
lt is also sad that the
team was probably deliberately chosen in such a way
that the people who were
still waiting or who were holding the shares
will get you further
in hamburg trading over the counter
some of them, including
paul singer, will get their 30 euros
and that's almost twice as much as the
compensation offer from before the good for
those who thought and didn't
have it, so to speak, there is here in hamburg
in the whole country is him so i think
a story about the reporters
are also discussed beforehand the
founders of von  good games so
quite relevant games studio they have
earned a lot of money two very,
very smart green guys from
hamburg they actually bought
a private wrap warriors capital
so i know that i think
they bought almost four percent a week
parallel to this elliott and slim so to speak  about
this pad
then i have made this
bet exactly  bedded with the aluminum and
i also find little money so there are
guys like our age
who then somehow bought a lot of percent
from rocket what was that for
the cab brand 34 billion euros what
so there it is serious then
you invest a lot of money and
we create work with it if
you know your way around and have the
relevant facts then you
can really make a bet like that
and what would
probably be my cushion
I think something between 307
million with it  made with the one
goal that today would have been 20 percent at the peak of
20.2 percent or so
and you can definitely say that is
probably also undervalued was
at the rate at that time wise holding had a
discount but there were people
and things like that clearly
developed well at the
time so it was probably a
very smart move by them well i
don't know  whether they just
tackled a cushion or came up with it themselves
so that
the small investor associations or protection
associations for securities shareholders did so many things right,
who of course were very annoyed and
i think 2021 was the best
year for investor protection overall  be it because of sex be it because of the
excesses typical of babbel in stock culture
that will probably remain an
example of this for a long time, maybe
also why looking at the future now is
one of the biggest german
IPOs something like a porsche or something like that says
look at everything  it's much more
interesting that it's really too far
away from the digital world because that could
be more exciting again right that you would be
there in germany if
porsche as
well should actually be taken out or rather the
word would be so i wouldn't
say that's a bad stock
is I also think it is rational this
separating these brands from it because they are there
now the parts say what a
very classic logic I think is always
worth more than the whole thing from that's
why he's smarter I don't believe
in cars anymore
+
so I strongly believe in digital and
software that  I've always wanted to be
well versed in growth companies
which doesn't mean that saying the
only one is one of four processors
can somehow make it very balanced
you can invest completely diversified
you can also only invest in value
stocks again but my
nature would not like Porsche now
meet for a variety of reasons, but
that means that from the point of view of the VW bosses
or i think it makes sense and
maybe as an exciting option
for people who like porsches, i.e. who
probably benefit from the fact that
people who may not
be able to buy a porsche but then at least a
porsche  i would
assume that you have shares for the long term  works well
then you see then he
wants to be there in the next few months that you look at it
now independently because I found porsche
there is a German tradition, so to speak,
brand others are off course for
me now a topic that I like to
watch anyway but  also the duo was
since i think what
is expected by many is hot expected that more clearly
the around 46 billion is one of the
expensive one of the most valuable is still private
companies because europe
europe is a sensation i
fear they have to hurry up a bit
because you  has been a bit
slow are raw ghost that
the nokia model can also be
regulated that's god galloways have been
agitating against the model for a few weeks
it has really
driven and I think I'll
say it like that then they've always seen it  will
that people simply have
debts or end up buying something exactly
that but actually pay  but can
thus pay later believe crisis now
and then
somehow private problems are
driven by such models and I would say if you
get the latest iphone now which you
will use for two years or a new
macbook or
a home trainer that will definitely do the trick
are those a bit of a question to
distribute if you write it off accordingly
as well as a business of course
also writing things off or finance it
whether you now have to pay your mango
bills or zara bill to 1 operator
that just has to be
questioned whether people don’t know how  you say
losing the overview that in the usa
i think even more dangerous with
the form he says up to 30 percent
partial interest so if something
would fall under book interest in
the usa then i would almost say
it is ultimately pay day loans so
say yes credits credits over the
internet more or less with selling
and the danger is I think that both  e
companies interpret themselves a bit
differently that the meshes are getting
worse and growth
could also come down or try to get
more growth out of the cooperation with
amazon but i don't think
that they will come out well with good margins
if they go with amazon is there
not a successful one exactly and if if
it couldn't come in there then
the window that one
also speaks of in the case of IPOs could, so to speak
, close again for planners quickly
if regulation or more comes on the stage again
and worse numbers don't have
that's why I think  so i can have q1 q2 for a long time
will almost be enough
to minimize the risk a little bit
let's be clear
that a
topic is discussed exactly comes in any case at schalke not more precisely
edit will come today completely
overrated but on the other hand i would
n't mind  rants because it has
great potential to become the next mini
market, we ha  ben it at gamestop at
just you saw last year
certainly something that is not
good for the stock culture but talks sometimes
they are already starting to
benefit the same provoke that they
say so we want our
users to become shareholders too that shareholders become red
users so they
actually want to make it a community project he
has the ip that means
no matter how expensive it will be
probably enough believe in it
and if not it might be
fun to cheer for so i would
definitely not locate it although for an
advertising-financed business a
bit
They also have premium models but I'm
not super bowl right now, but as I said,
I'd bet against it. The
hosting division of 1&1 will
probably
go public this year, so Jonas 1&1
then has the telephone DSL business and a
web hosting business  from one can have his
domains on his website
that was together wed  t split off from the
private equity company
and will probably go
public on its own
it's very exciting because i have the
feeling that hosting companies are
a bit like the new energy suppliers,
so they have very calculable cash
flow because the domains are usually very
long  are held so over ten
years is probably the
average holding period for the
domains and who posting contracts you
have a bit of a risk that you new
things divx or jimdo or square space
so but these website construction kits from
which make a bit of the market
snatch but overall believe  i
love the very predictable model that's why
private equity is i think even
if you get involved the companies can pay
back the debts very easily
from the cash flow is actually
a very nice model for private
equity but it will definitely be listed on
the stock market, says jonas  from the
topic courage 101 or exactly ge has  just
increased his shares in 110 there
was shortly before new year's eve shortly after
christmas he made himself a
christmas present and bought
so many shares for half a billion
that he is now back at 50.2
percent 5.1 percent is a 1 1  said
the majority again
solaris bank could come so
that the german will also
probably unicorn very
likely and otherwise ecommerce
would probably go into action war about
the model could come is worth around 50
40 billion flipchart ecommerce
in india where omnipotence i think one
can have a very large share that's
clear with the
exact scooter can hardly be very
are supposedly burdens ebitda has
been positive for the last two quarters
i don't know the market
well enough to be honest but they say that the
youniq comics are really so good that
they work  can i see
myself as one of the best presse.com
a preferred brand i.e. i  no
fair with whom I actually ride the
scooters the most sorry
[music]
and what else do I know exciting if the
rapid actually also war commerce in
latin america where it's been much more common for a lot longer
so I
actually have my suitcases on the way here
lost on the train understand that
and in brazil it would be completely
independent that i could somehow have a white
shirt brought to me within 20 minutes
from the nearest massimo dutti store
or mr peek &
cloppenburg with rabbi they
will come there but they still
say  so big i think around five
billion maybe that
's actually a bit of a hit
with glad that i think we made
a very small investment there as a minority
so anyway made
a lot of investments
maybe they'll be like that  at glowe
also reach for the majority before
doing the new bio while but already
considerable  che improvement of 20 percent
or as well as telephony itself is already
worth a lot has there is a
whole range of apps and
I find the Germans somehow
so landesbank jonas and then from
locally parried yes it must also mention
the kepler farm that is a company
from  greifswald that
actually is mannheim 890 founded in 2003 was
taken over by the brown family and then there
are those who buy patents
that are
expiring as i understand them a let's say a
bit over the top of the highest
profitability
peak but enjoy patent protection so to speak then
those who produce those buy  as
generics, so to speak,
seems to be successful making
somewhere between 710 680 million
sales with it almost called district house
kaiser should also go public next year that's for
the founders of
the area that's better for you, i think,
because he's not from the
region but soon
there is a pharmacology
faculty at the u  ni greifswald and
script gave on the riems on the ring
is but remote island there is an
animal medicine worth here quarantine
institute the friedrich loeffler institute
aser are so animal diseases and so
on then lies that means there have always
been many many pharmaceutical
scientists probably have
one  that's why they're also based there and
because the wages are of course still very
cheap there and they've raised it quite well
to now 6
million sales and that should also go to
the stock exchange ok I can't say
if I'm investing a
year old so locally patriota but it
always come back cool thing from the district
want of
course the ruhr area is like
everyone being that you can be
if you are another topic that we
wanted to tackle again and i am
happy that you thankfully
included the webcast and is one of
those who  Quite normal
feedback, man, we didn't do that very well
g  efallen and that should also have
space here because I use pens as a
representative for many who might
also say
that people are cool but but then they can
record everything illuminated differently. That's
why we're a
little bit which
episodes they liked last year  and also which
ones didn't like what
you find interesting because he's not the
christoph gerber greetings there
is also someone who every now and then
says the installer somehow
needs to ask more questions
or
this spirit now  again not
invited so you are also someone like that
only does it in the evening and the consequence is
threatening now i thought to myself why not
talk about it like you would like the
water who liked it a lot last year
what he didn’t like so i
just looked through it again  Where I
'm from and so I've found an
estimated 90 percent of the podcast
really should say that already
well
what i really liked where i
remembered it even without support
i liked the one with
tombstones i actually found
it super interesting so i remember
exactly that you heard it at
the podcasting it was in that case in some
highway tunnel in is
we don't do well because he
said a lot of things to me at the very beginning of
doppelganger podcasts so we don't want to advertise
ourselves at the beginning
says a bit changed
but that he appreciates independence so much
i found everything very exciting
and also  i found his theses on
journalism extremely interesting
johann könig i found a great
podcast with the gallery owner who somehow has his finger
on the pulse also at our
christmas party is also the podcast
apparently keeps with us had also
changed super so so i would
try on  puls made his own
podcast took it back with
me i say we have mathias döpfner
ha  t even that's an episode so
i buy we also do a lot that has
built a kind of pilgrimage site in
berlin with its new gallery that
everyone knows him so listen here too
i think i don't have that nice biggest
johann of mine i thought too  although
i'm not a football fireworks display at all a
particularly big football fan the
podcast with uli hoeness and abdi was
really good actually i don't know
why somehow the chemistry must
have been good that
maybe because they like to see each other
not only in the football world
but a little bit as a marketer and
manager I think it was probably
quite good when you have such
a sympathy or are disturbed or
that you have grabbed a bit of vanity
so you really talked very
freely but highly
entertaining and very interesting even
if I am a good federholzner
I found the poker player super exciting fred kogel
maybe the hypochondriac this dr
small story  te I think that's also
super exciting he's also able to get something out of
this unknown
branson that's
even succeeded I think because accompanying the ipo at the same time
is super exciting
to understand and how
we honestly told the day after that
say what is also not as cool as
you think and what is also totally
exhausting and also exciting if
I like
kliemann I found it good
logically one of the
most successful ones I read today
was
stefanie schmidt I
actually learned a lot about her
influenza wave like the one
that can happen now it’s from the founder of herschel
i think it’s a very crass market so
certainly controversial also a very
charismatic of
course many people belong one way
or another the classic one logo and
heinemann is if i
like everything of course
I didn't like it that much if
I said it was the absolute low point
ch i also wrote so
we are honest one can i say
i was angry
because of that it was also on the day of the kia instruction saying it was probably on the
day of the uplisting from the social hub with
the brisk kofler and ralf tummel here
so maybe a bit  in a
champagne mood
defense there I found it really
surprising that the kofler himself
still says on the supervisory board a big
shareholder brussels gent that you
then tell your own story very very
strongly seen by others how do i follow
myself at all expressing myself like that and the
people you that  complete the opposite and
the thing is when the podcast came out the
share was somehow at
58 after the uplisting is now at i
think around 35 you would have
invested there now and absolutely whose
champagne
mood got involved but 40 percent of the money in a few
weeks is for superstition  that's
sustainable so you think that that's that that's
the culture of the company jet  currently
the ms can no longer be i
believe that they can be worth more
if you continue to keep the
currency of your own shares so
high if you get the price and
stabilized and then continue to
roll out other models and then
buy more companies  of course it
increases in value overall the
investors were of course always
improving then somehow
you have to refinance the purchases if it's
profitable you can maybe do it
with borrowed capital so that the
sun can get rollup strategies
and buy up smaller businesses and
I can imagine  although
you also have to think about what is going on now.
bernd is there are just as
many private equity companies that take a
look if they are big enough they
probably look a
bit smaller than the typical
protect multi player so they would
n't be one now  take the cycle off the stock market
or something but look a little smaller
but it certainly also competes in
part with such razer models us
version i.e. amazon buyers and the
question is do they have
some edge in the long term i.e. only the means with
the offline trade what the advice the
pictures bring with you i mean why
did i do that of course they are
two exciting people who i
've known for years now but
i have to say i also found it
acceptable of course also the criticism may have
existed back then somehow it was
but has the feeling straight out of the
currently there makes that is
n't yesterday  it's not
particularly digital now either you say it's a very
very solid business i have the
utmost respect for advice when
i say i think i also think it's so
hard for the layperson it was for the chain
group it was all in there
too  take and they have now
not even paid for the fact that at the price to
buy probably good well act
whether there is now any ne so have gla
I not only practice it myself,
but there should be 50 million or so
calculated in the long term,
I don't think so right now, so I
don't think you with the audience
is the social chain, maybe even
maybe don't own it,
somehow sell the products from tires now
Can't you think I
agree that ralf had a good product department
here and that's good can place things in
offline retail that these are
now products that are also doing well online
so i have serious
doubts that you can already work here
and there  but that it
now fits together the way it is
sold i am relatively critical so to put it simply
it should have been done and yes
me if the deed is in the public
interest is of course different and im
dazzling personalities who put
their own order together where that is too
There are many people who are interested and
who like both of them in any case
promised sore spots in the career
absolute and so i have to because i'm
always a fan of people who are in
the media world are like that my mean
i might not have given it to the
room so that means you can
be switzerland, so to speak, we then
you have to at least if someone has built a
bit too much
i found my city, so to speak, from
the kings bay capital of german types
but very young type, really
big ones but of course the
phase that also goes right across the bed in the
emerging markets then was  the
story of five percent of the wines from
growth is still 3 percent that this
whole bangladesh stock market
is of course there is a risk that it will
be because the market is so illiquid of
course and since not many people are
investing now that if you put three
to five percent in there  then of
course you beat the courses
yourself and
then you may create the
facts yourself that you brew  nt to make the women
look good the question is whether you can get
the money back out of
bangladesh or get out of the
stocks when the price drops again
we have to say he is missing
the other side of the coin so to speak of
course people tell you that
of course, of course, and
people then take it at face value
and
probably not every
listener ends up understanding 100%
what has substance there, which maybe also
good storytelling, it
's always difficult to classify
and I think you're big enough around
people  would also come here to get
married I think I have to come
here when they are on tour because yes
I think a few questions could ask
certain questions
so there is yes I think you
have to you don't always have to put
your finger in mega  put the wound but
just either say it yourself, so to speak,
that could also be the other side
is tori just tell and  the person also
has the option of clearing
it up or reacting to
it well exactly otherwise somehow
everything that somehow ends with meyer
first of all angermaier from have to
be careful also
can only express myself to a limited extent
but it can so overall i know
it's cool I think it's the mix, well
, the fact that I'm usually a poker star
there, as well as a uni
fan model,
there are still people who
find some ice cream makers or something so cool
about the mixed overall,
think it's very good, not wrong
understand saying i'm not you get
so i'll write to you in the same way even if
i think it's really good i
think if i write criticism the goal
two or three times a year but it's
important for me so i'm here now
not inviting people unnecessarily but  as
the christopher of power, for example,
also with suppliers customers also someone
who could make us the others in his
life mic  h also every
time he always made fate
again
i don't know about everything and
really try try a lot from near
and far at the point also thanks
for the feedback even if it is sometimes the case
that the book gives the direction
or and  I've already
written that to the mayers offline
, of course you always have to
see a bit of the context of the time, so
especially in such babbling times there are
enough
formats that cheer everything up and somehow everyone actively
thinks it's cool in every IPO there was  So
also this unspeakable episode in 2000
when I knew the starting field anyway had
this freedom of the press things
which I think was very sad
I think it's also important then
and that's a bit
our sport doppelganger
also where it just isn't
it's okay to say the risk can be greater here
than the chances now i think i have
a very good one the last time
The following is a list of companies that have
been skeptical about their negatives since the beginning of last
year and which then really
all lost half of their value even more
, so you made your
pink list better than the euro
is exactly how you would have the long short like that
traded it would be relatively successful
so we had tesla wrong that
can happen that's just a
lot of others already have it and
we all i was actually surprised
that of course it's a concept that
many want to win so see vegan
food but i also found it relatively
expensive  we're still in relatively
good shape so far I'm not sure if it will stay that way for long
but otherwise we have sorento one
way and now I can believe from jessica
alba billiton would have been exactly then
with many really or with zoom it
was foreseeable very early on that the numbers would
not  you can see that a
bit if you've made the
effort  ut
met somehow where it was
relatively obvious, at least for us, that
things about values have actually come to the stock excha
ge reference t
api mio everyone wh
hears us here regularly knows our colleagues because conversatio
s but what do you think about it we are also allowe
to do a very, very small part  being involved in
the company
at mr what the colleagues from premium
do is real-time market research
within minutes you get
representative answers to your question
so you go to the meeting and ask
yourself is the slogan cool understand
that people want this business model
viable that  use people or
something like that tests it with api
million very large companies are already doing this
in the red bull vw lidl beiersdorf and also
the day on youtube video if
you want to cure it short mail to pr at
from the colon com and you can
then directly first  to start a survey
[music]
then a few other
trending topics are now gone again
from stocks to me from other
trending topics to come your your day for
the next few months also in the long term
so a monster word that
will come up everywhere now it will be there at the beginning of the year
or in the middle of the year at
the state of the internet video keynote
that i  because I probably also talked about
the metal burst
as is as what is happening in the
second half of the year it happened
completely exploded not
because of us but like facebook
mainly magdeburg was also
very big but also many
others want to  look meter what
is coming that is pure luck what
you saw too early so super
hit ever a brand developed does your
production build the dish really well
i definitely think that will be the
topic in 2022 so that microsoft
apple probably facebook substance
I'm afraid that will have substance
. To be honest, I'm
not just skeptical  n even very
threatening so i think it will be the
first major technology where the
negative effects net outweigh the
positive ones you can
now i look at everything very
skeptically but i'm not
critical of technology per se or anything like that i think i
'll say that  everything that we
invent generally has at least some positive
effects, always has a few negative
social media effects, i think it balanced itself out a
bit, there were a
lot of positive effects, there were also
relevant negative ones, i'm afraid it will be
a bit in the beta
for the time being  it can be that it's mostly
negative, which
you think can happen a little bit like that, but
what then determines that like it was back then
with live and
stuff like that and then there's no user
numbers and then it gets rather
unexciting yes you  you know best how to
inspire something like that, so when
beyoncé then has the only concert of the
year  rt or somehow the
super bowl can be followed meters at once
worldwide from the
stadium the top acts will probably
be thrown full of money commitments
to perform there
and in the end it
's going to be kate kate's plate by because i think everyone
wants that  just winning and above
all facebook facebook urgently
needs a new vision a
device strategy and with oculus it
would be super exciting for them
i think 8.1 million
cars were bought last year with more than microsoft
xbox is sold were 49 open
then  at night the search is said to have
gone up in smoke the app was
i think most of the downloads are after
christmas
that means thinks facebook really wants to
win it has to
win that means they will do
everything possible
and so what i'm missing a bit is
where it comes from, so to speak  since productivity
or a new branch of the economy in
economic life in st  marriage but lives there is
somehow cultural or productive
progress i just don't see that and
at the same time i see that if it
works and we somehow bring
relevant time or only some of the
people relevant time meters further
then it immediately has adverse
effects on travel on gastronomy on
everything  what physical goods are, be
it clothes or maybe cars too
i think it is a relatively
historical world when wenlock people
start out as somehow people will
probably only feel incredibly
bad at home if they are really
tied up there are of course
people who give states of age
the opponents deal with it then for sport
the turn lead
concert or for dating in there and
then out here too but i'm
still afraid that maybe young people in particular
or people who are
less mature will become more
important if you say them  how
bad the people deal with soci  al
media are already
so I'm the German aspect before that
at least as I'm following it too
but I'm of the opinion that I don't think it will
come that hard outside of
the gaming world I'm already there
with envy or exactly where that
's all from  have taken place it's
in deflation not only
recently also it wasn't even
back then it was said then it was like
that then something happened in the games that
the people sometimes were
n't even able to play in the games anymore  and
spending time
and having doubts watching film trailers
or concerts so getting out of the
field i think in the end it's
like
the emergence of a worldwide social network
it's almost a
black swan event that
someone will succeed in the pandemic a social network  to
build and live that is
used worldwide that's what mark
zuckerberg did once with facebook
and then no longer had
anything to do with it g  If you buy it together and then nobody has
managed to repeat something like that again and again and so I think
replicating a black swan event that is
so rarely that difficult even
with as much money as facebook has I
think it's right that we do it now and it
's likely  it's
all logically understandable but I
think it's just incredibly difficult and
accidentally so improbably easy that it's possible to build again organically, so to
speak, but otherwise between
the over buying that it's
also with me or even more than
that that's
why I'm that  again from the
same company it actually comes
statistically relatively as well as you can the
statisticians it is with that next to
an airplane there is a bomb inside what
a statistician does because in the same
room with because the chance would be more
than 2000 billion that's no different
with that  about that but
on the other hand what you can already see that
facebook also a bit di  e
has built rails on which other
networks can emerge very quickly,
so instagram tik tok that's
also grown very quickly because well
, if you look at how quickly the
network gets to the first 100
million users, then it's getting
faster and faster, somehow like instagram  has it
faster than facebook makes whatsup
faster than instagram tik tok
faster than everyone has so far
and since facebook has many
users and with the
appropriate incentives it could
be but the question is how
likely is that yes but i
think so if we  i would think
it very dangerous frankly and being
in the hands of facebook right now
doesn't seem to be the best stewart to
say our cultural heritage
from so i would like you
to reach yours too what
goes with galloway's agitation about it or or
position where it  is pretty clear
and certainly a lot went
wrong and you can ma  n
definitely discuss, but whether that comes with what is going on
overall, I'm not
really convinced myself, how does this gaming
world have it, is it already there or
maybe I have to ask a bit what
is 1 meter, which is really exactly
that, well  really a totally
ambivalent word and if you like
we already live in the meta it's from
wozzeck communication zoom calls
phoning de facto somehow not
meeting people but still you can
talk to people people like
fall in love with people via instagram or
children that's there  Yes, everything recently
belonged to the podcast in which Matze stopped
at the driver's. He was told how he met
his new girlfriend. In
fact, everything was also digital and then
it took me months in Vienna before I
met them and then there were a
few worries  for that,
if you will, that's more than just not just
ge from a single company and via a
wide variety of applications hi  nway and
then we've already
arrived there then we don't have to
talk gaming anymore or on facebook then
it's already the
pandemic after two years there are still a
few new services for the ace but that's
already there  the question is
what finally another
trend topic nft
itself
recommended to us we should do
more nft now because get active i
think there is on the way but of
course hundreds of other
thousands of new buys find adidas makes
things
johann könig makes things  climate
does things wherever you look
what do you think there is
no need for a pft right
now yes there i would take your opinion again for example
and well i think the year 2022
will spread brutally
i.e. 50 percent of the clubs no matter what sport
will either
have
tokens or energies i think or sell some events or teeth or something like that i
think it will be a lot
ma  market penetration the us girls
create in order to take love you know that's exactly how
as a sports club you always have an
incentive somehow things that aren't
marketed yet so christians new
marketing opportunities new budget
why not take them with you and
probably build even more bonds with the
fans me  I think it will assert itself very
strongly and also in other
areas of music, maybe music rights,
maybe events,
so I think that will come up very strongly
. The question is what happens
when you have your first 10-20 fps at some point.
You can
ask them everything  have enough everyone has
enough use of it you also notice that some
are just made of and eat
really good concept behind it is
a bit like all other
tokens or crypto might be
like that at the beginning there was a lot of euphoria
but then at some point on  at the end of the day,
where you are stuck, there are also
concepts that make sense at all  inter
for your more for not probably
very exciting if within nft he
gives me somehow lifetime access to the
events is good especially cash flow
first of all if you put it to good
use the question why
orf added offline is even more exciting
than  become a tenant because you can
probably spend 200,000 for the first time,
so
the intern and the junior marketer
can finally somehow go to the festival without
hamburg not having enough hotel beds for a long time,
the sheer size is limited and
probably we can do that too
200,000 already at the conference today,
there are actually
a lot of
event platforms
that have of course also often addressed us over the years, especially now the
pandemic
, or of course also addressed them
in the market and show what
they have there and how virtual events are now
can do and
looked at each other and I wasn't
really enthusiastic about that
he avatar always like that around
pushing him so slowly loading 3d
worlds freedom so that has just too little to do with the
real experience what we are trying to
convey that i have enjoyed myself over the years
or what would like to
be played
you can say okay
then the first one has to be the first to even make the
turn and only be there again
and so
but still have to be british and
his can't do everything at the same time
and i still think that's
a long way off and i think you can of
course too  to make the virtual
day for them
so now shows yourself turn it works
and everything you can always do
for a day of cool things if
you really concentrate on
bringing facts together then you can
also do digital ones i want to
be sure but  I think this offline feeling
is something else, you
're still here today and that's why
at least there's also something like that
at all in this this european
super unicorn thing so events software
the website are basically eggs involved
so good for them but i find it
easy
otherwise it would be fft is i
actually don't think there is such a
real first mover advantage so i
think you can get that  also take a good
look and see what
actually works and so everything was per
when i mean this this reason was
but now an adidas and nike first of
all that is pure pr we take them
for your attention yes but
i think someone once calculated
that  at adidas i had to say that
if you assume that you also
immediately have an additional team where there are hardly any costs
against it, of course that is a
relevant part on saber that the
question of whether you
can reduce such things permanently
works so once i now a
few thousand euros
so it would be cool for us for everyone
it's more like that, of course it was a
bit  there is a danger that people will
learn that it's actually just manni
becking that people stop and that's why i'm ruling that out for
the time being, at least for the
short term, for us too for now
of
course we could sell something to the people now
and they would
definitely buy it a few people  but
it's not at all how i can really
create more real benefit from it and
then i also found it wrong to do
it as soon as i see a concept
somewhere but what works for me
that i
can then apply to us then it will be
determined immediately in  but at the
moment it feels like you
said people do it for pr purposes
or simply to take money with them what is going on on
the street and that will
not be there indefinitely so the budget
what the average consumer has left for
something like that  has
it is limited it will also
be gone at some point so something
sometimes imagine i think we are
both  we all agree that nfc technology
will find its use cases
and it definitely makes sense to us
these tokens that makes it so there
it is that is there jesus day and only from now on
everyone who should somehow jump on it
and whether they have their goal  so that's
why I become an artist or every
company that's why my vodafone
has also made itself very clever the
first sms because
the kriegergründgens also recently told me in the podcast it
was great in the end brussels dpa yes
never experienced anything else somehow
played worldwide never counted
probable  worth in the millions
or what is he said i think in the
eight-digit million sum
at least if you should have
paid for it a range or
attention
have now done so cleverly but i
think that someone is running
now you can no longer make the first
concept you  you can't anymore
at some point it's over and that means
this pure attention  it's the game
that runs out, so to speak, and then
you come to dirk elbers and then there are
a few but I don't
think I read quite so much in the ticketing area in the sports area I also believe the USA because
it's always been like that  with
trading cards
but i always ask myself with a view to
germany i don't actually
have trading cards here at all that's why i
'm always
amazed that it's so hyped in germany because here
you should have stamps and coins
but sports cards like football sticker albums they
're who  with 30
euros the old ones or with pictures from 19
86 they are somehow worth nothing but
not so easy but the usa is different
there they are really worth thousands or
will be or millions but it is
not at all why you should be digital
can be like that  be but in what is
broad it is at least not historically
it is already like that so if
we have from when but at least two
topics using nfc that you can now
hear everywhere and they will
accompany us but
if you do it I don't think I
know what exciting it is that
probably the first one is really
widely used without a use case for
queensland so you haven't had that
yet  seen a lot that has somehow reached
halfway the measure and i
think it can already be foreseen that
nfc probably knows what
five to ten percent of the
consumers will probably reach in
some form at some point and
this makes crypto once again
clear salon for the
probability of error then you will
sweetheart
I don't have any bitcoin right now I'd say
I would probably prefer a teresa at the moment, among
other things,
she also did last year, I think I did
please come if I'm not wrong, like
72 percent I made 44 percent,
so it's going much better and one
fts are now a reason to believe
that
probably is maybe  t at the
park or so run much better
because on these protocols and
meringer then to change it again and again
that's so that the software seems to me
to be the first really
meaningful use case that reaches the
width
okay okay okay  so a long journey
across stock trends podcast
what you could do to invest of
course again without any guarantee
and recommendations through life
business angel investments
hemberger so congratulations on that plattner i
'm sure we'll see you here again in a
few weeks or months
that it is
also hopefully running at the event
so there too he would certainly be there
as a double for separately alone
however always on regarding individual hand over
if there is a band that we
believe we have been working on of course it had to be
dismantled in the last resort is
doable but we  hope very much I wish
you yes wish yes many many thanks
no, the one who sees is above all yes
and exactly for me the first really
big question of the year in the first half of the year is
definitely yes
what happens there
but ok we unfortunately don’t have
everything together even with a lot of
night shifts you can’t influence everything
in that sense first of all thank you for prince
dubai we will come we
would like to hear from you now there are doppelgangers podcast
meanwhile also many others i
thought what now with jan thomas christ
you are a guest you are somehow
across the scene meanwhile well
read the newest member german
digital intelligence  year that was
not mentioned where the
[laughter] was
fun until
next time
for all those who have
personally decided to continue their education in 2022
I would have something and
that is we have an area that we finally
have mr education and  Among other things,
there are so-called deep dive courses
and we have specific ones  deepen topics very much
get you further
e.g. in the area of seo in the area of instagram marketing i
the area of digital analytix in the area of e-mail ma
keting you can learn a lot within a fe
hours a lot of added va
ue for yourself and you also f
r your employer who does that
would like to do intensively practical
either live and of course also digitally
and a personal
certificate of participation at the end who can take a
look at what you are offering and abyss
com is currently available with the
voucher code there may be 22 10 percent
on all courses so another acquisition
point may come  stayed visit
[music]
this podcast picture produced by
popstars
billion